[Musica]
mi dicono sempre che sono stato
fortunato
sento sempre dei pezzi che mancano
Qualsiasi cosa succeda è sempre colpa
della mia storia le frasi che avete
sentito sono tolte da storie di persone
a cui questo accade da sempre
perché hanno in comune l'esperienza
dell'abbandono e poi dell'adozione
e oggi sono qui per parlarvene perché se
amiamo l'essere umano ne amiamo le
storie di vita per lavoro ascolto
racconti come questi che mi vengono
affidati per cercarne insieme il filo
conduttore perché raccontare è un po'
Come prendere coscienza e può
trasformare gli angoli in curve come
cantava De Gregori per tutte le persone
adottate arriva un tempo in cui
guardarsi dentro e indietro non per
tutte allo stesso momento e non tutte
allo stesso modo perché poi magari
qualcuno non intraprenderà alcun viaggio
dentro sé stesso ma per tutti arriva il
momento ai tuoi pensarci
perché una storia iniziata in un altrove
che sia 10 minuti di auto o a 10 e più
ore di aereo non importa ci racconta di
un appartenenza da ricostruire magari da
rifiutare o da accogliere a volte da
inventarsi nuova ma comunque da qui non
poter prescindere per chi ha una storia
di adozione trovare le parole che gli
assomigliano di più per raccontarsi non
è scontato e io faccio questo ti aiuto a
trovarle
perché
credo fermamente che si possa in questo
modo trovare il proprio
modo
per sentirsi interi e completi
ritorniamo alle principio
vi siete mai sentiti dire che siete
stati fortunati mentre voi di quella
fortuna avreste fatto anche a meno
alle persone adottate il cada spesso
perché troppo spesso si dimentica che
prima di essere bambini fortunati perché
con una nuova famiglia sia stati bambini
abbandonati e questo non è mai una
fortuna
dicono anche che sono fortunati perché
la madre almeno li ha tenuti non li ha
abortiti come se questo potesse mai
essere in relazione
D'altra parte però non è neanche una
Sventura deterministica essere adottati
non è una spada di Damocle che da
sentire sopra la testa e non significa
che siccome la propria vita a questo
bagaglio un po' pesante lo si potrà mai
essere sereni o completi
vi siete mai sentiti come se vi
mancassero dei pezzi
a chi ha una storia di adozione accade
spesso di sentirsi scomposto
come se mancassero sempre delle tessere
al proprio puzzle Ovviamente sempre le
più importanti
Ma io credo che si possa raccontarsi e
rirantarsi la propria storia Tutte le
volte che serve per sentirsi finalmente
interi anche se mancano dei pezzi
a volte si troveranno a volte invece non
li si cercherà neanche
talvolta invece lo si farà perché è
fondamentale farlo per se stessi
quale che sia lo sguardo che si posa sul
proprio passato
sono certa che si possa trovare il modo
di sentirsi interi
anche se manchevoli forti fragili o
spezzettati
Vi è mai capitato che vi venisse detto
Come chiamare vostro madre è strano No
perché tutti sappiamo come chiamare la
mamma
ma alle persone adottate capita anche
questo perché di madri c'è più di una e
spesso dall'esterno viene detto come si
dovrebbe chiamarla
e invece di madre e padre si possono
sentire in tanti quelli che ci sono
stati prima e che vi hanno fatto nascere
e quelli che ci sono dopo e che ti
crescono Perché ognuno ha fatto quello
che ha potuto con gli strumenti che
aveva come sapeva e li si può ottenere
ognuno tutti insieme perché ognuno di
loro ha un proprio posto che cambia nel
tempo ma è sempre lì dove lo si può
trovare dentro se stessi
vi siete mai sentiti come se il vostro
passato fosse tutto ciò che importasse
anche se voi siete molto di più alle
persone adottate capita spesso perché da
piccoli spesso viene raccontata la loro
bella storia ancora prima di dire che
sono loro
da più grande invece verrà usata come
una giustificazione per qualsiasi errore
commetteranno
e da adulti invece potrà essere come un
sasso che viene lanciato contro per dire
che tutto il caos che sono viene da lì e
non essere libereranno mai
a volte sarà invece il vostro corpo che
sembrano tradirvi perché dirà un
appartenenza che neanche Voi sapete se
sia proprio quella e da capo tutte le
certezze se rimescoleranno
su una cosa però hanno ragione non si
smette mai di essere stati adottati fa
parte di sé e sarà così per sempre
per fortuna
perché questo ci dà la libertà di
pensare che la propria storia non è
immobile e granitica Ma che invece potrà
seguire tutte le diramazioni della
propria vita
e io credo che il punto sia di imparare
a sentirla come la compagna di viaggio
perfetta presente ma non invadente
parlare di adozione non è mai facile
spesso lo si fa con tanti stereotipi o
seguendo frasi fatte
perché l'idea di abbandono che sta
dietro all'adozione porta degli aghi
potenti dentro quasi tutti
e ci parla della paura di essere
lasciati soli di un appartenenza da
ricostruire e non poter mai dare per
scontata
e anche della distanza che c'è tra
quello che si sente intimamente di
essere e quello che invece il mondo da
fuori ci rimanda come risposta
i termini usati per parlare di adozione
sono spesso polarizzati e si portano
dietro echi di gratitudine Da dover dare
o di buone azioni da ricompensare
e questo necessariamente va scardinato
da qui il viaggio che voglio raccontarvi
4 persone che condividono delle storie
non tutte uguali ma simili ma
soprattutto che condividono un'idea
quello che l'essere stati adottate le
riguardi non solo come un fatto
personale
condividono quindi il pensiero che si
possa condividere le storie di adozione
non per usarle come al solito come
testimonianze o come modello da studiare
ma che si possa invece usarle come uno
stimolo per un nuovo confronto con il
mondo esterno e che possa servire a
superare gli stereotipi e a riconoscere
invece l'universale che c'è in ogni
storia creando dei nuovi spazi di
dialogo tra le persone adottate e la
società
dicevamo Quindi
quattro donne 4 persone tutte state
adottate e tutte provenienti dall'India
Buongiorno di dicembre si sono
incontrate per un pranzo che doveva
essere di chiacchiere e invece se sono
alzate due ore dopo con il programma del
primo progetto di legame adottivi
legami perché quello che interessa Loro
sono le relazioni tra le persone quelle
che vanno oltre i legami di sangue o
meglio sanno reinventarli
e adottivi perché ovviamente l'adozione
era un fatto principale
da qui a dicembre 2019 siamo cresciute
siamo perché una delle quattro sono io
e con le mie amiche diventate colleghe
abbiamo cercato di portare sempre di più
le storie adottive fuori dal loro
contesto solo personale e fuori dalla
narrazione tradizionale che ne fanno i
media questo però non con l'intento di
salire in cattedra di rivelare delle
verità ma piuttosto con l'idea di
ripensare insieme e riflettere su dei
temi che sono più universale di quanto
pensiamo
perché
appartenenza
multiculturalità identità razzismo sono
tutti i temi che appartengono a tutti
quanti
E questo vogliamo farlo in prima persona
per portare finalmente la voce delle
persone adottate al centro del discorso
che le riguarda per creare parole nuove
servono spazi nuovi dove confrontarsi
senza la paura frenante di commettere
errori ma invece dove ci sia la
curiosità di andare oltre le certezze
che credevamo di avere
per creare parole nuove servono spazi
nuovi
le storie ci parlano
ascoltiamole
ascoltiamoci Grazie
[Applauso]